when you were playing baseball
would you sip lean ever no no never
because i mean
would you even like if you were to would
that even be something that come up in
like a drug test
uh because it's technically cough syrup
i don't know
is that a thing is a baseball player
slipping lean right now
yo okay what year were you drafting uh
1999.
oh [ __ ] you was it drafted with right in
the steroid era
oh oh [ __ ] did you ever participate in
any steroids when you're playing
any hgh or anything i'll still be
playing
yo [ __ ]
today's day bro barry bond his head got
so big i'll still be playing
he's hitting 30 and still in 30 bases
you know what i'm saying you use the
base still you stole a lot of bases
yeah but see i'm one of those dudes i
really like be worried about my body
right now i was scared that you know i
was gonna put some [ __ ] in there and
i don't know you know what i'm saying i
was always worried about that your right
leg stopped working huh
just take the wrong thing it was tough
you know because you got every pitcher
in the steroid area everybody throwing
97.
ain't nobody throwing under 98 miles per
hour
they all [ __ ] well he was still i
just had to get through it the best way
i could
wow what yo which pitcher in your
opinion was the the
the one who scared you who you were like
[ __ ] here we go yeah [ __ ] i have to face
randy johnson i'm from arizona come on
man brady johnson
that's your boys
randy johnson my favorite picture ever
coming from way behind you
[ __ ] randy johnson and he's [ __ ] like
six foot ten yeah he's hot see now cece
he was a tough pitcher as he left the
tube i hit him well but he can't get him
from the top
randy johnson coming from right here so
randy johnson was the guy who sticks out